if you know why I'm holding this cheese
grater today then you've been paying
attention to the Internet this week
what's going on guys my name is David
Tom and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about Apple's latest
and greatest release the thing that
looks exactly like a cheese grater
that's right we're talking about Apple's
Mac Pro the 2019 Edition with ridiculous
specs and a ridiculous price point now
the reason that you're seeing this video
a week after the keynote speech is
because I wanted to take all the
information that's come out onto the
internet and compile it into one single
video for you guys to make it easy to
understand what this new product is all
about and know before anybody asks this
video is not sponsored by Apple just
take a look at a number of subs and the
views this video gets and you'll know
for a fact that nobody's sponsoring this
video well I guess maybe I'm sponsoring
the video I do own a company called wire
watches if you want to check it out the
first link in the bio and it's all about
architectural design timepieces violence
so let's talk about some of the specs in
this great machine you can get anywhere
from 8 cores all the way up to 28 cos in
this machine but what's more impressive
is the fact that you have 12 doom slots
to fill up to 1.5 terabytes of RAM now
it's very hard to comprehend how fast
and how much 1.5 terabytes of RAM is in
a machine the computer you see behind me
has been custom-built for video editing
and architecture design work right now
inside the tower there's only 64
gigabytes of RAM inside 64 gigabytes
versus 1.5 terabytes
that's like going back to the old USB
sticks that only had 32 megabytes of
storage inside of them this is a crazy
leap from what we have now to what we
will need in the future and its really
future proofing and allowing everybody
to slot new cards in when they need them
as technology advances in this
exponential rate that it already is
going
the base model comes with one AMD radon
pro 580 X GPU inside and it can be
expandable anywhere up to four AMD chips
the story itself also goes up to four
terabytes four terabytes isn't so
impressive anymore considering that the
new matte
or pros come with a four terabyte option
as well so four terabytes on a very
expensive machine potentially not enough
but for the time being it is perfect and
obviously to power so much performance
inside a single machine that you need a
lot of power coming from power source
I stand that it comes with 1,400 watts
of power directly supplying everything
that you need inside the machine now or
for the future so let's talk about the
actual size of the machine if you're
familiar with computer towers then it's
very simple to explain it's only about a
mid-sized tower if you're not familiar
with the computer tower well it's made
me about that big that's the best I can
do for now at the top you're gonna see
two metal arches which are basically
designed for handles to let you move the
tower around a third handle has also
been carefully created inside the top of
the shell where you pull twist and lift
to allow you to take off that whole
shell and access all the components
inside on top of the case there's two
Thunderbolt ports and the on button
personally I would have liked to see
some USB ports at the top here as well
because if you're selling this to a
professional everything is going from
USB to USB see and the professionals in
the industry aren't just specifically
using Apple products they're using
everything from Canon to Microsoft to
Nikon to red cameras and everything in
between
now obviously with this much stuff and
this one performance and same single
tower it's gonna need a lot of fans to
cool it down on the front of the case
there's three fans and on the back
there's a single fan ensuring that a
constant airflow is going throughout the
entire tower the whole time okay so we
haven't talked about the price yet and
that's because it is ridiculously
expensive if you're living in Australia
it's come out at eight and a half
thousand dollars for the base model
that's not talking top of the range CPUs
that's not talking twenty eight cause
that's talking the bottom of the barrel
and the worst thing is if you're only
able to Shane like this you're probably
gonna need a premium screen to go with
it luckily app will release the premium
screen to go with it on the day but
that's gonna cost you another seven
thousand dollars so in total you're
looking at anywhere between fourteen and
a half thousand dollars all the way up
to twenty thousand dollars and over
Apple hasn't actually said how much
they're top-of-the-range MacPro is gonna
cost but everybody is speculating that
it will be near the value of a small car
there has been a lot of banter and memes
on the internet this week about the Mac
screen and that's because the strain
itself doesn't actually come with a
stand the stand is sold separately for
an extra one thousand American dollars
so there we're talking another sixteen
hundred Australian dollars so if you
want to take this computer home set it
up and have it on your desk with a stand
you're looking at over fifteen thousand
dollars for the base model now if you
look who these now if you actually take
a minute to look and understand who this
product is marketed at its industry
professionals who are out there spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars almost
every single year to make sure they can
produce the best quality of work it's
the guys out there in Hollywood creating
movies it's the guys and girls out there
in Hollywood creating the most epic
cinematic Hollywood movies that you've
ever seen making sure their colors are
pristine and perfect and making sure
their workflow is incredibly clean if
you've ever exported a video today in
2019 chances are you've sat there click
render and wait in about two hours for a
half an hour video to export imagine
what would happen if you needed an
export a to three hour long 8k full res
raw file you'd be sitting there for days
and weeks on end that's why these guys
need high-end towers and performance and
also color perfect screens in the
keynote Apple actually did compare this
screen to thirty five and forty five
thousand US dollar screens which means a
seven thousand Australia dollar screen
versus a fifty sixty thousand
Australians screen well in my personal
opinion is an obvious choice there which
one you go for